former USA Gymnastics dr. Larry Nasser's
ex-boss is in a Michigan Jail this
morning the local sheriff says it's
seven-year-old dr. 7070 rather year-old
dr. William Chappell was arrested
yesterday trample was Michigan State
University's Dean of osteopathic
medicine when NASA worked for the school
criminal charges are expected to be
announced later today the arrest came
during an investigation of the handling
of sexual assault complaints against
Nasr more than 250 women and girls
including Olympic gymnasts accused
Nasser of abusing them he's serving
prison sentences lasting more than a
hundred years dr. Jon LaPook has covered
this story extensively John good morning
good morning in his position is Dean
Williams trampled oversaw Michigan State
University Sports Medicine Clinic which
included Larry Nasser in December
trampling outs he was taking a leave of
absence due to health issues but he has
long faced criticism from victims about
how he allegedly handled their
complaints I knew that he had abused me
I reported it in 2014
Amanda Thomas sho told Michigan State
University that Larry Nasser sexually
abused her during an exam at an MSU
clinic Michigan State University had the
audacity to tell me that I did not
understand the difference between sexual
assault and a medical procedure the
school told Thomas show an investigation
had cleared Nasr but did not share its
full conclusion with her she was unaware
the school told NASA and his boss
Williams trampled it had found
significant problems with Nasser's
conduct strap will establish guidelines
for NASA like having another person in
the room during sensitive procedures and
limiting skin-to-skin contact
Larry Nassar was cleared to practice
again under new guidelines that were
never actually enforced according to an
MSU police investigation last year
Strabo said he did not see the need to
check up on whether the guidelines were
being followed the investigation also
noted at least 12 sexual assaults took
place after Thomas shows 2014 report
most of them in examination rooms at MSU
I believed that the adults at MSU
surrounding Larry would do the right
thing in 2016 gymnast Rachel den
Hollander
became the first of Nasser's victims to
publicly come forward she filed reports
with the police and Michigan State
University where she was treated the
response of Dean Williams trampled was
to send an email to Larry that day and
tell him quote good luck I am on your
side
this is the greatest scandal in the
sexual abuse scandal in the history of
sport attorney John manly represents
more than a hundred and fifty of
Nasser's alleged victims if dr. strand
pol covered this up and he himself
engaged in misconduct he's right now
exactly where he belongs
MMS whose president said last month the
university was moving toward firing
strapless ighting he did not act with
the level of professionalism we expect
from individuals we reached out to the
attorney general's office Michigan State
University and Stram poland' have not
heard back msu police directed us to the
AG's office the shoes keep dropping in
this case again we specifically don't
know what he's been arrested for exactly
stand by in a way we're gonna have more
for you later tonight on the CBS Evening
News with Jeff gore all right